[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks, Nathan.
Hello, so I'm Eitan, and I lead
our developer engineering team
on Google's Project Tango.
And at the beginning
of these talks,
I always like to take just--
show of hands, how many of you
have heard of
Project Tango before?
OK, so maybe 1/3
of the audience.
So for those of you who have
heard of us before, hopefully
this will serve as an
update, and for those of you
who have never heard
of Project Tango,
I want to introduce it to
you and tell you a little bit
about what we're doing.
All right, so Project Tango
stems from this observation
that today interaction
with our phone
is fundamentally limited
by the area of the screen.
And whether you're
at home shopping
for an appliance online--
slides, OK-- or at work
planning for a project,
or out at dinner
socializing with your friends,
your phone is with you,
but you're still just
interacting with your screen.
Your phone doesn't
see or understand
the world or your environment.
And on Project Tango, we
want to break this barrier.
We want to teach your phone
to see and to understand
your environment and to augment
our own abilities to answer
questions about the
world around us.
Now, those might be questions
like, how much paints do I
need for this wall?
Or will a couch that I'm about
to buy online fit in my room?
I recently made a very bad
decision with a sleeper sofa.
Or how do I get from
where I am to the laundry
detergent in a store?
And of course, and
most excitingly here,
we can make games.
And whether we're exploring a
landscape with Possible's Poco
Eco game in full six
degrees of freedom,
or dodging meteors by moving
around our room with Danger
Dodgers from Uppercut
Games, or competing
with a friend in a multiplayer
Jenga experience, which
was a partnership between
Jenga and Schell Games,
or even just placing
a cat on a surface
by you to have a
new virtual friends.
I've made a lot of
progress with Mittens
over the last couple of weeks.
Project Tango allows
us to build all of this
and to do even more, and we use
special cameras and inertial
sensors on the device
to allow your phone
to see the world much
like we do and to build
a truly human scale
understanding of space
and motion.
And we expose this understanding
to application developers
by adding three core
technologies to mobile phones,
and I'll talk about each of them
briefly, motion tracking, area
learning, and depth perception.
So motion tracking
allows Tango devices
to track both their position
and orientation in space.
The device keeps a log
of the visual features
that it sees in the environment
and calculates its position
and orientation relative to
static features in the world.
Area learning allows
Project Tango devices
to recognize spaces where
they've been before.
When a distinctive visual
landmark-- think like a stop
sign, or something like that,
or a special painting-- is seen,
the device stores
this in its memory.
And the next time it or actually
any Project Tango device
comes into that
space, the device
sees that visual fingerprint and
recognizes its precise location
in the world.
And depth perception allows
Project Tango devices
to see in full three dimensions,
thanks to the addition
of special depth cameras.
This allows them to
see and understand
the geometry, structure,
and scale of the environment
that they're in.
And there's no
better time to build
apps for this platform
than right now.
At CES, Lenovo and Google
launched a partnership
where we're building the first
Project Tango smartphone,
and it will launch
in this summer.
It's going to be available
globally and the US,
and it's going to be at
mainstream price points.
So this technology really
is coming to mobile phones,
and we're just at the
start of what we hope
will be a very large ecosystem.
And to this end, we've actually
launched an incubator program.
So we're always
looking for developers
to build interesting
content, and we
want to help make that happen.
So if you have an idea,
please reach out to us.
So that concludes my talk.
Thank you so much for listening.
We're excited to see
what we can build.
You can check out our APIs
on developers.google.com,
and you can email me directly
if you want more information.
And with that, I'm
going to introduce
Sunil who's going to talk next.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]